once again the social media mob going
after
the girl scouts the organization was
forced to delete a tweet
that congratulated amy coney barrett for
becoming the fifth woman
to be confirmed to the supreme court the
girl scouts
later apologized which is worse and said
the post wasn't
intended to appear political all right
dana so cancel culture is infiltrating
everywhere
and it doesn't even take yes for an
answer first they come for the girl
scouts
next it's gonna be the bluebirds dana
look the bluebirds um remember the
bluebird pledge to finish what you begin
and there was a few other things
all good lessons that you learned this
was
so disappointing what did we really wait
say that again what was that
that's when you pledge i pledge
to finish what i begin like like your
projects like
making sure that you don't like start a
bunch of projects
i know because i can't remember the rest
of the pledge
do they still have the bluebirds i used
to make i made this cute little thing oh
it's so cute
little badges and everything anyway what
i was going to say is
i think that it's unfortunate that they
um
apologize i think that what would have
been more brave and would have set a
better example
for the young women that they hope to
raise would be to say
this tweet was not intended to be
political period
but no apology if they must say that
it's not intended to be political fine
but you don't have to apologize as you
were saying earlier greg about being
intimidated
why why would you teach girl scouts to
be intimidated that's ridiculous
absolutely no it's terrible you know
katie they're these are the same creeps
who don't raise
any objections over looting arson or
even these recent beheadings
i don't think they were sending you know
they were outraged over that but this is
what they get mad about because it's so
easy to fake outrage about this stuff
well look and i don't feel bad for the
girl scouts i'm on their blog right now
and they have a blog post from 2011 and
the title is hillary clinton
world leader girl scout so the question
for the girl scouts is
are they really all about girl you know
women's empowerment girls empowerment
for all of us or are they really an
organization that actually is political
for one side while pretending to be
non-political when they have to delete a
tweet
yeah juan shouldn't why are the girl
scouts on twitter
shouldn't they just get off it yes
i think you know they they think of it
as marketing right but look
i think the guerrilla scouts are a great
organization and i think they did intend
this to be
apolitical but you can't get away from
the fact that they were politically
a little bit blind to the political pain
of people who object to a rush
process that was highly political and
don't
think that this was good
you know what the other thing that you
learned is to be a gracious loser
a great organization jesse
listen the only thing i would say i want
to just talk about the concept of
backlash
backlash is not when you say something
on twitter and liberals are upset
there everyone that's a liberal is upset
on twitter
just if you go to like a vegan
convention and eat steak
that's going to upset the vegans but if
you go and eat steak anywhere else in
america
it's fine
well done yeah now i'm hungry